[Music]
today we're making another addition to
the uh world fantasy uh
the story about the um uh fantasy series
the first and most important part of
building a world a river
i think they branch out no no no no no
no just think about this
they converge into one pathway so you
got to remember that well when you're
um part two language not as important as
people think when you
have a fantasy language you can just put
words together so mordor is just like
more indoor frodo baggins is just a
it's a kind of crossword puzzle weapons
uh just
use medieval weapons doing anything else
is pretentious
politics it's a monarchy you know you
got to explain as much as you can right
from the beginning so
usually in a prologue get get as much
information as you possibly can about
your fantasy world into the prologue so
that
readers can can read that and that's how
brian sanders does it that's how
joe anaconda does it that's how that's
how er
look that earthquake hey lagoon
you